hi everyone what's up we are streaming
returnal um
i've not touched it at all but i do
really like house mock i like their
games
obviously playing on playstation 5
right now um i'm very excited to jump
into some of this gameplay i know
a fair amount about this game but i've
not watched anyone stream anything or
any gameplay or watched any of the
reviews yet because i wanted to
experience it live for the first time
myself
um and i'm excited to get to do that
so let me just want to make sure that my
layout is all
correct for everything here it looks
like it is
um yeah i'm just streaming on youtube
for this one
might jump over to twitch for the
remaining hours but i tend to try to do
these kind of debut streams just on
youtube
um maybe but i might be too tired by
that point
so let's do it this is the very very
very beginning of the game
and the controller is doing a lot of
vibrating
it's the rain it's giving me the haptic
feedback for the rain that's neat
i've crashed i survived but
helios did not this is very cool
status operational but my sidearm is
missing
i'm leaving comms open wow
this is also a this is literally the
start of the game um
like there wasn't anything before this
this this is it this is what is
happening
is that what i want to do i feel like i
should go back here and heading towards
white
and maybe look damn chica sprint
all right girl just like maybe
see if there's anything around you for
me to grab
oh very good oh oh that is some fun
traversal
okay can i do anything with helios
my my nice ship friend here or are you
just nah nah
nah you out let's go what could go wrong
just out here trying to locate the white
shadow broadcast it's gonna be
just fine um also everyone
uh i need to move my webcam higher so
that i'm not covering
that information let me do that real
quick um but i was going to say we are
raising money for
ablegamers um pretty much all of my
streams
are raising money for them it is an
organization that supports
disabled gamers move all of these up
come on bud hey
that one is locked this one has to go up
there we go does that work
yeah so now you guys should be able to
see all the ui i can readjust if there's
anything that um
looks like it gets gets missing jerry
you're right
you shouldn't be watching don't spoil
anything for yourself that said
it's gonna look different for you so um
yes i definitely think it's supposed to
have a bit of a scary vibe
that is the plan
haptic feedback look at you doing
haptics contains extensive runes of the
xenotypes oh i don't love that
ancient wolves makes you think of aliens
we don't have to say xeno type
okay they've been building a lot of
doors though
oh thank you it's alby i appreciate that
okay i guess i probably am streaming on
australian hours huh
all right i'm into the way this all
looks so far it's really dark
obviously i wonder if there's some
lighting variety as we uh get further on
but i also understand
it suits the tone
cool oh press the wrong button
okay this music's really nice too i
wonder if this is
something i can get on spotify it's very
peaceful scout log
i have found a deceased astro scout here
checking identification seems like a bad
idea
it's celine in case she didn't say it so
i'm just letting you guys know
that's her and i'm into it
my sidearm cool
that gave me chills continuing towards i
love it when video games do stuff like
that like
in a movie that doesn't mean anything in
a video game
that is uh you know focused on you
as far as i know um doing runs
um that's cool as hell
like when they tie the narrative into
the gameplay that way it's not like it
it's uh
groundbreaking or anything but i do
think that that is
always makes you go oh snap look at what
they did
all right i'm just trying to loot man i
don't even know if i need to be this
looty but when she goes as fast as sonic
the hedgehog
why wouldn't we okay what's this
okay look at you look at you have to
king
discover my gosh ps5 look at you
analysis for suit repairs
how long is the gameplay in this game i
don't know this is um my first time
playing it
yes jared that was in intended to be her
own
body kind of um
at least it was her it said celine you
know it's it's her helmet she found her
sidearm on herself uh i'm excited about
what they're gonna do with that
narratively oh you want me to access my
suit computer
that's going to be just in what status
interesting got lots of tegrity
and pretty much no equipment databank
a xeno fungus with unusually strong and
flexible fibers that are suitable for
repairing damage to integrity oh
interesting
i don't know what integrity actually
does yet but i feel like that's good to
know
let's keep going shall we oh it's red
oh oh my
hello
hello hello
hmm
i don't feel like i should be shooting
these are you gonna attack me
the answer is no are you going to lock
me okay maybe they're fine
this is the thing that i do love about
sci-fi games that have this kind of vibe
is um
oh there's a lot going on on the map
right now is uh
the wonder of it not knowing what
everything does
hello are you going to be uh nice to all
oh
oh okay hello
would we be friends maybe if that would
be
encountered are they coming for me oh
they are okay
what's what is all of this okay they
shoot
just little blue sort of balls
all right with that oh you're lower than
i thought you were
okay okay okay hostile fauna dispatched
everybody's dead then i think
thank you old stuff i'm very excited for
resident evil to come out
um recorded log found
adding yeah i intend to do like proper
playthroughs of it which i don't do for
a lot of games like pre-recorded
play-throughs but
we'll see how organized i can get
the last time 30 minutes since last
protocol i will not be recovered until i
reach the broadcast signal
if you're hearing this you are stuck
here too
very good i don't remember recording
that
i like it a lot um are the controls
fully removable i'm not sure
i do not know
okay that's gonna be that gate back
there i feel like this isn't gonna go
well for me but good thing i have sonic
speed
just went through everything it feels
great to control for the record
like one weird thing about this game was
there were virtually no previews
obviously it's a weird time to do
previews because of the pandemic like
i've done a lot of game previews
some of them like in very extreme cases
the game changed so much from
what was shown in the previews um
especially because you're seeing them on
the developers pcs rather than on like
it doesn't make a huge difference but
they're streamed essentially
um it's also just harder to ask
questions and
i don't know there are a lot of a lot of
ways that approaching previews right now
is very strange
this game did not have any actual
previews
uh so i've not really heard anyone talk
about it outside of the
reviews and stuff today but running and
jumping is my point
feels very good it feels
lovely which is not a thing i've heard
anyone talk about oh
oh okay okay okay well i will open that
door then
not coming back from that one
hmm
uh charlie i never said i was going to
only stream on twitch even in my
announcement video oh i didn't even know
i could dash there you go
um even in my announcement video i said
i would still stream on youtube for
things like this for podcasts um so i do
still stream on youtube all the time
i just mostly stream on twitch it's a
different kind of content basically but
yeah it was definitely um
definitely said that in the video that i
would still stream here okay that's
gonna be a longer dash one
hold nope i did it too soon oh
i can go down here i didn't even
didn't even realize okay interesting
it's definitely sly i would agree with
the prometheus vibes i would definitely
agree
okay
um use dash while in mid-air to perform
longer jumps cool
we've done it
siflum resin fills one slot towards mac
max integrity upgrade okay
ciflum and resin uh two in two separate
oh suit repair max integrity improvement
interesting
additional data needed so i guess i just
need to continue to scan things
30 minutes since lost crash oh does that
mean that there's a loop where i'm gonna
hear
the crash
because that's cool um did i not pick
that up
oh now i have it maybe i can equip it is
it going to be
in equipment not yet i don't think
that's cute okay yeah it looks like i
don't actually have anything in here
just yet um we'll figure it out
so what's what's all this then what's
the
what's the plan here security system
encountered interesting
okay that's the way i expected to go so
i wanted something new um oh no that i
didn't mean to do that
didn't mean to do that that was an
accident all right oh well almost made
the exact same jump
um matt there will be no new podcast
yeah it's just a live stream okay i'm
gonna run
jump we're gonna dash run jump dash
um i haven't edited the podcast yet
though so it'll probably be up pretty
late tomorrow if i'm being honest
cause my editor was not feeling well
i wonder how much any enemy variety we
will uh end up
getting here
because right now it's these guys who
seem to only have one attack but i guess
i'm not getting close to them and your
first runs for a game like this is
supposed to be you figuring it out
but i'm not really doing that much of
that
okay pick stuff up let's go
cool
oh you can dash through the lasers damn
it i wish i had a tried i just assumed
that i would die
good to know thank you they are totally
a bullet hell type attack
uh darth vader um the most recent
uh battle toads game has like a whole
level that is just the most mashy
version of that why are they screaming
um my hands hurt oh interesting
interesting i see okay cool
so i have to to get rid of my suit
malfunction
kill 10 hostiles
i love a video game where a plant reacts
to you kingdoms of amala did that
huge fan beautiful stuff
that's bad everybody's allowed their own
taste
you don't uh it doesn't have to be for
you you know that's cool
um all right this um
large ball i've discovered
is pretty ominous we're just gonna keep
going
this could be the sentients that
broadcast the white shadows yep
just gonna roll through that
ah it is impossible
right i love that for me it's gonna be
good i'm always brought back by
there is a moment between death and
rebirth
when tentacles drag me down screaming
drowning returning
it's almost like the name of the game
but not quite
um okay yeah i'm into this i'm into this
concept i like it
again i think this is a really good
voice performance it's atmospheric
you swap dash of the bumpers and would
recommend that doesn't seem like a
terrible idea
well uh i'll keep playing around with
this for now
because i'm all right with it being
acceptable oh
a largeman oh okay
well i didn't think that you'd be able
to do that that far oh
no okay i didn't know you had that kind
of range
my good sir um well this is where i
die first he cornered me
i wonder if there's a well it's okay i'm
probably supposed to die anyway aren't i
you're allowed to figure it out this is
what the returnaling looks
like
this is very pretty
i was supposed to die i was supposed to
die
um
second death i didn't die when i jumped
up the depth of
up the cliff though um we'll found the
game that's really dark
astra this is celine i survived that
oh you've been here for a while i'm in
my ship
safe status operational and now
okay
this is gonna be like your bedroom in
hades
this is an order get away from here as
soon as
doesn't sound great
i'm way more into the lore of this than
i may be meant to be
i'm into it okay celine vasus you're
hereby ordered to return abort current
fissure and its scout ship design helios
not been for the planetary study
required to prior to
exploration you're immediate including
acknowledgement
in immediate and permanent whereas
neglecting despite previous willful and
blatant is not
that seems threatening seems a little
bit threatening
do you see the white shadow
i didn't see a white shadow i was doing
it wrong
emily sanza has started a conversation
telling vassars has joined cecilia cara
scott has joined something major
happened is this
another emergency drill i'm still in
maintenance where is this coming from
the void where crossing has zero
galaxies remember when we were devoted i
think this was the reason oh this is the
crash log
maybe
distress signal oh this is them finding
the distress signal attributes has been
marked
approach forbidden we wait for clearance
i know this i've heard this before it's
hard to explain
you know this message what do you mean
celine oh that's interesting that means
that potentially before they even landed
celine knew that she was going to be in
the loop
so ask your protocol the ones who sent
the threatening message
private analysis information retrieval
in times of crisis evac protocol what is
evac protocol
doesn't specifically say supersedes all
other protocol and regulations currently
in effect regardless of mission status
or obviously directives okay
employee record that me renee
reconnaissance scout
okay cool um yeah i guess
i've already experienced this you sure
have love you sure have
all right let's seems like imma just
leave
every time you die you are returned to
the crash site without weapons artifacts
and resources collected in the last
cycle your databank entries and
permanent equipment revived survived
from psychosome easy permanent items to
explore the areas and utilize shortcuts
what are the permanent items
just the sidearm i guess i will collect
permanent items as i go
all right let's go ready to return all
some more well this is
quite different my mind
oh you can jump okay that's all right
that's
that's fun fun for everyone
i didn't know they could do that up
close either i also don't know if i have
a mealy
i'm not sure
oh the sound design right now holy heck
a lot of spooky clicking going on no you
don't
know me all right no you don't good
thing when you shoot them for that far
away it's pretty useless
so big dummy
um i think i need to drop down anyway
look at this idiot thinking he could
shoot me from that far away when all
he has is this one attack that just
shoots these same balls
the exact same formation well and that
meaning attack that did get me
should i jump into the water
is it going to kill me let's find out
brilliant i [ __ ] knew it
oh well you know hey
learning experiences and that
i think we can dash through these we can
actually just walk through these
this is pretty chill all right
beautiful
we've done it we've done it that doesn't
count as death number two as it turns
out falling doesn't count as dying in
this game
alright just one death but there will be
more where that came from
as soon as that big guy shows up again
don't like my chances
i was not prepared for him all right
who's mean in here i can hear you
making creepy clicky noises oh it's this
making noises
[Music]
weapon technology discovered
augments my weapon with an alternative
firing mechanism
okay i love the jewel sense doing this
stuff um this is what they were talking
about in state of play today with
ratchet doing this
that you have technically like two
separate abilities with the same
i think it's really cool very neat
um just a good way to use the
the hardware in that so eliquid
good way to use the hardware in that oh
i gotta get rid of this okay so then we
just
highly effective oh my this will be well
hello then didn't expect that
very cool oh wait wait no i'm trying to
use my alt
could you guys just wait a second no
hang on
oh [ __ ] fine i can hit bio
just do that take care of one ear i do
keep overheating i need to watch that
so it's can i not oh maybe i need to
equip it
i can hear equipment equipment or
can i only use it one time
i don't know how to interact with the
things
it seems like this menu is still only
these two things that i actually can't
do anything with
right now and then the data bank is
obviously all the data so what just
happened to that thing that i
unlocked suit augments
i can't really navigate this either oh
wait what am i looking over
i can't see what i'm changing
i don't know what i'm changing
basically right now um very basic
and i'm thinking that it's probably that
i have to charge up the
bottom left to make this work again oh
hello
is that big boy again if yes
what if we didn't um
not that i know what my goal is other
than to murder you and everyone else on
this planet which is not very chill of
me
if we're being honest it's him isn't it
the music makes it sound like
everybody's angry at me
the aim is very forgiving uh can i get
hit
dang there are several of you
um because they have so their hitboxes
are so big because they're so
technically
i feel like because i've started playing
most shooters on pc i really do have a
tough time
whenever i have to jump back over to
console
um but generally we'll always prefer
like an action adventure or
anything of that nature with a
controller
yep that was a stupid jump because i was
reading the text
okay
it wasn't so bad i
kind of hyped myself up a bit what do
you do are you gonna attack me
i would really like to find out
i shouldn't
okay cool
this is not cool at all actually i take
back everything
positive i said about whatever the hell
this is
hello bambi welcome oh new gun
neat
acquired a xenotype weapon similar to
our carbine technology
that's an assault rifle ma'am that's
what that's gonna be
i don't know if you're familiar with the
weapons as you are just
when they say she was recon basically
she's a recon scout
[Music]
uh i'm familiar with this
hello new boy discovered a massive wall
beyond which is the white shadow center
oh
this is a large wall she's not really
can't cross the chasm hello
for now where are you going objectives
and investigate the energy reading in
the forest okay cool
well that is very cool though
it looks neat also there's some kind of
explosion up there i take it
i did not expect to be as interested in
the law
as i am i
don't doubt that the gameplay is going
to be a good time
as you get into more environments
um as you get you know upgrades and more
weapons and all that stuff and you get
some mastery of it because obviously
right now it's very new
but i did okay
okay um but i did not expect to
be feeling this law as much as i am
who triggered the broadcast
do you see the white shadow is something
only i should know
and now out of literally nowhere i'm
hearing it again
because it's you where the sentience
involved a good question
she's a pretty nice butt is it a bad
time sorry i need
to believe there are answers at the
signal
tyrion said the concept and even the
monsters they copied straight from edge
of tomorrow slash lived i repeat looks
like a nice game of the originality
please
i do not agree even if there are similar
concepts this does not look like edge of
tomorrow and also
tomorrow is actually based on a manga
anyway so
but i also think i fight against that in
general things don't have to be original
to be good because most things
this just looks like i should shoot it
it's also not an assault rifle i gave
her so much sass
and it is not that which respect
they gave me an expectation based on the
way that it looked and it does not
control what i expected at all love to
be confident and wrong
so that's what my shortcuts are going to
be that they were referring to earlier i
think
hello my friends
so there it's an assault rifle clearly
what yes dude
i can't shoot it that way yet though
loving that hip firing is effective here
feel great about it
after playing that resident evil demo
which is the first time that i have
played
the shooty thing on ps5
in a while
i was like oh my where is this
hot damn
rub rub damn
rub what
yes good and also i keep pressing square
to reload even though i don't need to
that's on me um all right
why does it sound like something is
charging up
it might have been my own gun uh
i take back my concerns okay i want to
go to whatever that ledge is
but how i don't know that i can
still just trying to find this broadcast
really
ah the atropian key yes of course
i don't know that i can get through that
yet oh hello
aha great it was a very god of war
looking
chest
listen no my br
my brain tells me that i should swap to
the new weapon just to experience it
but i like this shock thing so much that
i'm not going to do that
okay research things
it's like hades in space
that seems bad we don't want
that um can i shoot you open maybe
no
what are the mysteries of this land who
knows
it doesn't feel like god of war with
guns no it does not
i just meant the chest is like not a war
um i'm wondering if there's a way for me
to open that up but i also
don't feel like i need to be spending
this much time on things this early in
the game
so
we are going to keep going let's see
what's this though
can i go anywhere from here oh
g'day mate a bit spooky
am i enjoying this game so far portal
player yes i am i
definitely am um like i said more than i
expected
maybe
no i don't know i don't know
thanks jordan thank you so much
all right let's keep rolling i could
probably investigate further
i do think i might have left some items
behind them but it's all right
you know we got a lot of video game to
but i worry play day i will
re-experience these same
interactions from their perspectives
but are they truly me or just hollowed
corpses
this may be the face of things to come
i'm so into it
i never pause a video game to listen to
an audio lock
is it going to kill me no
are you sure it feels cool all right no
killing me
what is this question mark oh that's
that's the thing no that isn't
what's the question mark
ah okay
let's keep moving
hello my friends
hipfire
can't even really see them it's fine
making it work oh
anybody else wanna didn't mean to do
that
bad timing gentlemen i don't have enough
charge for that okay oh
what's that who are you down there oh
hello new friend
who is he you're you shoot a lot faster
exciting um okay let's take out this
dude first
the one up on the top there but they're
both pretty close to dying and
are not terribly intimidating
um all right so you just have that same
attack pattern oh
well looks like it
oh does it have to recharge after that
third shot maybe
i'm just trying to learn everyone you
know so that as we go through more of
the
returnals that we understand them
um okay what do we got laying around it
sounds like somebody else is still
chuckle [ __ ] around yeah you can see
them
hey bud get absolutely wrecked
shield vial neat oh yeah we'll pick that
up thank you
cool xenotype device acquired i think
this will prove a useful tool
i don't know how else to explain the the
dual sensor um
in more detail i'm sure people who are a
lot more eloquent with describing
hardware could probably do a better job
of that than me
maybe some of the reviews have but um
this is certainly a controller
experience
um does it make you feel more tunnel
uh it um oh
he's his uh oh his eyes oh oh my god
that's what those do i when i said it
before that i was like i should
investigate what that thing does
i didn't do it and now i found out it
scared that
crap out of me my stream's delayed i
want to see my own reaction
was so fun so hard that it shook the
webcam
oh god incredible um okay
yeah that might have just been a trick
to get me to stand there in any case
i don't know that his yellow eyes
necessarily mean anything
i don't think they do no
i'm a scaredy cat what is this plus up
here
is it down here maybe this thing i still
just don't know how to open it
not sure we'll figure that out later i'm
sure just keep moving
find more things to terrify the [ __ ] out
of me
yeah i wonder if resident evil cap ons
is gonna do some dual sense horror stuff
i mean this
is obviously using the triggers um and
the two sort of separate modes of the
triggers
uh for different firing types um a lot
of vibration going on the rain at the
start you could definitely feel on the
controller
it's um it's doing a lot
um i tend to like it oh my oh my oh my
oh my
oh he's gonna be back big boy's gonna be
back i swear
you you wouldn't give me all this for
nothing
stupid big boy it's all right hey
maybe the game still wants me to die i'm
still learning it's okay you're allowed
to continue to learn
so then you can return all over again
can't use those we know that can use
that
though i don't know what those things
are doing i should probably be paying a
little bit more attention it is a
problem learning a new game while
streaming
is it like trying to manage so many
things that you i i always have to
relearn
discovered xenotype technology on the
corpse of a sentient
scan is indicating potential for suit
augmentation
oh is that going to let me interact with
the little orbs this is going to be
permanent
i'm feeling it appears
safe to repurpose i don't know the um
the jewel sense isn't using the speaker
for anything right now
performing a function test to confirm
generally just regular feedback
like it just just vibrated then and
again
your suit can now use trans locators to
teleport
well i already know what that's gonna do
let's check this room out
see i was worried about big boy but
instead
i got a teleporter
okay
wait did i do that
are they just bouncing
i'm trying to figure out if the design
the the the choice to have the rocks do
that is tied to
me moving or if it's just happening i
think it maybe it's time to be moving
um okay activate
neat confirmed
point-to-point teleportation location
exit seems
fixed so i can't teleport
over to that is what you're telling me
i'm gonna try it
oh okay hang on
if i can control it at all i can't okay
but we can go down and get that
chest though
great cool love a malfunction
i'm gonna stick with the shield and i
don't know how to get to that one
jump back in go on my nice little old
adventure
[Music]
that's a lot of noise um
we can leave it it's okay alana use
you can let things go for now and then
we'll make our way back up to that
the teleporter that was uh up through
here somewhere
seems like a good idea this one
here we go i'm the best
oh that was a fun little adventure
oh my hello you're new okay
everything is uh very easy to kill so
far which i will say i strongly
appreciate
but that means to me if it is all this
easy to kill
that um end game or just later in the
game in general is going to be extremely
difficult
i would bet money nothing that
starts this easy doesn't scale to hell
it's gonna be a bad time um
okay this way i don't think this is the
one i came from
nope maybe it is okay
it is not this is new
okay well there is a
pathway back here but i can't get up
there probably no that's not gonna work
we'll go this way okay
um keith there is not a difficulty level
i don't think but it's also
possible that i didn't pay attention i'm
sorry
well yeah i figured thank you though i
appreciate that
um no i don't think so but i i do
imagine this game gets pretty tough
which
i'm generally here for
all right okay hello
it it is very prometheus like the inside
of the tombs feel very
prometheus discovered xenotype
technology that produces other devices
no i'm so cool with this one i have
nope tell me what this is yes
oh i see okay
um let's do it
neat okay
that's all this is gonna be i think and
i'm still not taking this because
i don't want it um
device to change the other and overlines
for one another that seems supposed to
do something okay well yeah i
intentionally didn't start the game
online i generally don't do that
oh
that's the worst thing that i've ever
seen
i'm not a fan of that at all no thank
you
all right
it just says object potentially
beneficial
well [ __ ] i'm here
evidence of rudimentary xenotype
language discovered
oh i don't have cyphers currently
lacking resources to decipher
interesting
cliff i don't know jason
thank you for asking um while i do
work at sony um i'm a video game writer
i cannot tell you how to access your
digital deluxe weapons
for this game you know we don't we don't
talk to house mark it doesn't really
work that way
i don't know uh
particle fever very into the story so
far what does this do
this is a long distance traveling okay
we're not gonna do that yet
neat all right
another potentially beneficial um
oh that's gonna give me a cliff
discovered a fragment of the xenotype
language
that looks like doom language
uh what was i saying yeah very into the
story so far
still certainly a lot to learn but uh
conceptually i'm
way more on board than i expected to be
um i still need one more yeah
that's what i thought so
i think we're gonna keep going forward
okay this is like your shop
basically middle section it's not like
it's um uh
an unusual for its genre like it's
definitely following the wrong like
setting sort of format that anyone who's
played it before will recognize pretty
quickly
but in a world that does feel pretty
unique hello you're a new boy too
oh oh you throw things oh you threw acid
and you take a lot more hits
did i get stuck to it i keep thinking
that i want to know what everything does
but i don't want to die but then i'm
like but isn't dying inevitable
death is just inevitable man is that
going to hurt me
is it did you throw it at me enough that
it will hurt me
who knows oh i don't have enough
you can do that you big jug
okay okay
yeah generally when you start one of
these games you kind of should be being
more curious i don't know why i'm
trying to conserve myself i am
definitely going to die and i have to
restart and i
just pace myself back by how little i've
been learning
but here we are
just just really not feeling the deaths
right
i'm now to shoot any light i see
well dante it is very easy to die and
should be in theory
um
ah there's so much stuff that i don't
know how to access i don't know how to
get up there
um because they expect you to die as you
learn and you get better gear right
um but i i don't want to
i don't know i'm scared of these [ __ ]
things now get get away from me stupid
[ __ ]
okay it seems like there is a lot of
loot in here that i can't access
um but i no longer have my malfunction
oh my okay
oh well hello
that's going to be fun
oh i thought i would have made it um is
that it though
anything no okay let's teleport again
shall we
oh oh i didn't see that one
okay this game is definitely going to
get really disorientating
which for a game on a foreign planet
that you're not necessarily supposed to
understand i also
am into i like it what
what every corner i just
i just what uh can i not jetpack up
there no you can't
jetpack quite that high so like if we're
talking about up the top of here
i could no i don't think there's any
i mean i'm not getting from there that's
not gonna ever go that far you know
um i'm sure that there's something that
i'll unlock later that will uh
answer those questions but for now
no okay
you have a shield though i see so i'm
not sure
how to approach that shield cannot be
taken down by the looks of things okay
maybe we take you down first will that
maybe take out somebody else's shield
potentially no shield can't be shot down
i mean i could run past all of them i
think
but i'm gonna need to know how to get
rid of shields
eventually i imagine look at that eye up
there that's
that's cool
just as i got hit okay um
i might die here but i kind of want to
continue to investigate the area
i should learn to read the map though
shouldn't i so
right i can teleport between these
things but i don't know that i want to
do that
does this what is the difference between
the gates mean is this an open gate that
i can go through
and i didn't i think it is
i'm not positive of that that is a side
path
that i didn't access either so is this
one
well why not we can always come back
here
and my guess is that i need some kind of
key
that i have not gotten from this area
yet so let's jump back over here
good timing good timing
the map is a little bit like um fallen
order a little bit i can see the the
touches of that that you're seeing for
sure
um okay so what did i want to do
i hang out here we wanted to go this way
to this side path
through here that i did not go to before
haptic feedback for the rain is like
weirdly peaceful i really like it
uh okay i keep forgetting to hold it
ah that's good to know
i probably wasted it though you can
probably only use it once right
okay all right okay hey thank you for
the the donation i just realized we got
one for um
ablegamers thank you everyone i am
trying to raise fifty
thousand dollars for
ablegamers which is a charity
organization that supports disabled
gamers
um we got a fifty dollar nation from
mighty d and from gang thank you guys
appreciate that um it's a very cool
organization
i keep trying to support them through
pretty much every stream that i do what
oh
scared the [ __ ] out of me this is a
really interesting atmosphere
because i'm not actively scared
um i'm very unsettled um
yeah just very like
oh no worries kiss i follow uh
the playstation tag on instagram um and
i actually think i did follow ghost of
tsushima for a while i follow god of war
so i get to see a lot of cool
screenshots and like people's gaming
setups and i do tend to like a lot of
them it's
it's a good way to use instagram
actually i think is to follow tags
you see stuff that you wouldn't
necessarily otherwise all right i want
to go to this side path
i don't know that i need to though
what is uh
what is what is that thing the that's a
proximity translocator we've already
used that one so this is gonna be that
room
where i fell to the floor and i wasn't
sure how to get over here i'm just gonna
try
oh
did i not do this
okay oh oh okay
what a fun surprise for me how wonderful
wow what a what a nice
coffin that was [ __ ] sharks
disrespect
okay cool great i love that for me
um okay
so what is that
that's just a device that was the nap
device
the nap device is what i'm calling it
from now on um
these question marks don't know what
they are
but we could head back in that direction
just keep exploring because at some
point i'm going to need to find a key
for that
oh it's an upside down triforce but
opening the vault seems like the correct
step
to take um i want to find another
teleporty boy
which is which way is it it's out this
way
i really like this map too yeah
generally my first
impressions of this game are really
positive
though obviously full disclosure again
people always make fun of me for making
too many disclosures but i always want
to do it because
it is both honest and people will abuse
you if you don't
um i do work this out i do not watch the
house mock
and i am allowed to say whatever i want
about any video again
stream other games all that good stuff
um but you know
do with that whatever you want um
okay so this is that first room that i
didn't really need to do anything in
let's come out here
i can't go through this
i need some kind of tech so then back up
this way is just going to be
okay let's see what i can do with this
door
i just want to know if i've tried them
all you know
does anyone respawn
it looks like another uh there wasn't
one in here yet we go straight ahead
you stupid [ __ ] things the devil
okay we didn't go through this way let's
go
well looks like this is gonna be a gun
i'll scan it
i really like my current gun
but that's stupid [ __ ] it okay
interesting this is cool oh wow okay
alana
you should be paying more attention
it's much more shotgunny
the bad time for that ui to show up i'm
really not paying
enough attention to the way the um the
like energy for the weapons works i need
to pay more attention to that
you're a jack you're a big fat chuck
and you're dead okay cool
a broken calibrator oh my oh it was
lockdown the lockdown has been lifted
now
um i like my other gun better i'm gonna
stick with this one just to teach myself
variety of weapon
as said um all right
i should go this way first because we
know it's a side path
welcome javi uh my day was good thank
you noah busy work day today
thursdays are always really busy because
i work all day and i start early
this doesn't seem like a good idea love
but this seems like a bad idea
does it though no no no no no no no no
that i did not agree to this
you did this
yeah no it's gonna like impregnate you
oh my god it does not appear doesn't it
though
doesn't it though somehow
it's strengthening and weakening my suit
i wonder if they do different things
auto repairs while at low integrity
greatly increases mealy cooldown
again i've not used merely one time i
was wondering earlier if i even had it
so there we are
cool you're absolutely right steven
she's doing
real dumb stuff just like the crew and
prometheus this is how we end up dead
love
okay it's a really bad idea
uh what was i saying oh yeah thursdays
are busy i start work early every second
thursday so i can do a podcast called
presence of mind
with greg miller and khalif adams
um that's gonna be my dead body again in
it uh
that is specifically about like mental
health and video games and we talk to
mental health professionals and it's
it's awesome but it does make thursday a
pretty big day
um on top of all the stuff i wanted to
stream because we've got pokemon snap
and return
yeah i just also had a bunch of meetings
today i'm gonna keep going through the
doors for now
okay hello
the good news is you're not very good at
shooting downstairs
but i am pretty good at shooting
upstairs
so oh [ __ ] actually
just the regular fire on this is
does it fit oh boy well okay i thought
he
he'd not be that direct with it no no no
no no no
no no all right we're all right
yeah i thought that that stream would
have
buried a bit more but it's cool he's
dead i really still need to pay more
attention to
when i um overcharge great sound design
on the
again keep doing it a lot you know that
you need to fix that
but you keep doing it so you only have
yourself to blame
probably not now we can probably wait to
do that a little bit later dead
this electric stuff is very good
i feel like i'm melting people
nope
all right all right all right all right
all right all right all right one more i
think
oh what's this that was just a way
showing me oh yeah i should scan more
all right cool anybody else trying to
trying to chuckle [ __ ] there is somebody
else he's up here
hello mate
not today and i think that's everybody
in this area dead
clearing out the life forms son of a
[ __ ]
all right yeah i mean this environment
is constantly evolving
okay let's go let's do my little
teleporting port
back up here i don't remember where i
fell
still don't know how to get through
these oh i had a mealy actually
i should i should check that at some
point um
we're just for now we're just grabbing
some stuff and then i i should probably
end the stream
at some point i should be streaming for
over an hour
okay is this gonna be
something i should shoot or still no no
it just
one time it worked so now i think that i
have to shoot everything that glows
it just moved a little
[Laughter]
oh man i do not like it
no no no no no no
okay
jeez
there's a lot more to do in here let's
go to the side door first shall we
can't do that okay what do you got for
me
well i don't love that also what is this
[ __ ] parasite jeez man
okay cool what is this
versus dos who are you
xenotech device for accurate
reconstructions of complex entities per
environment
why on earth would i want to do that
i guess we'll find out
um all right everyone i'm gonna leave it
there i was gonna jump over to uh
also stream on twitch but it is pretty
late at this point
so i think we'll leave it at that um
it's 1am so i should probably go to bed
um i am planning to stream an hour of
pokemon snap here tomorrow which i'm
also very excited about
and then uh jump over to twitch on that
one for sure
um still raising money for ablegames for
all of those but yeah just wanted to
give everyone kind of a glimpse of the
start of the game
let people you know see the beginning
aspects of it
i'm very into it so far um definitely
really like it
uh i hope you all have a wonderful
friday because it's friday probably most
places in the world at this point
and i will see you all next time